three two one zero India Space Program
successfully blasts this unmanned rocket
into orbit the chandrayan 3 is on a
mission to reach The Far Side of the
Moon but it's only cleared the first
hurdle in an estimated month-long
Journey
through his journey towards Moon
[Applause]
our Dr lvm3 has already put Chandra and
three craft into the precise orbit
around Earth
170 by 36 500 kilometer was this
intended target orbit and it is
precisely there now
and let us wish all the best for the
children three craft to make its further
there's Pride at Mission Control for
thousands of scientists monitoring the
launch at Satish the one Space Center
near Chennai but Skeptics have
questioned how billions of dollars spent
on India's Space Race who benefit
ordinary Indians government of India now
has announced its policy on the space by
which
external companies or private companies
can participate in the developmental
activities
which would mean
there will be larger potential for
employment
as well as some innovative ideas can get
a good shape no craft has ever landed on
the South Pole of the Moon
a scenario of interest because frozen
water is present on the lunar's surface
it could potentially support a space
station
if the chandrayon 3 lands on the Moon in
August India would only be the fourth
country to achieve that feat